hello everyone and welcome to one of the
most expected encounters from the 2018
European Club Cup it's a Magnus Carlsen
representing his chess club Avila Ranga
from also against the Dingley rains
alkaloid team both of them playing of
course on board one and it's very
interesting this is a one of the few
tournaments that are organized in the
world that so far carson has not yet won
so it really would mean a lot I guess to
him to win this tournament win first
place for his team and only then face
Bobby was still being rated number one
in the world and before we check out the
game and its really really a wild game I
did prepare their score so far so it's
interesting if you consider only
classical games cross and never beat
ding and the dings never beat Carlsen
they played three classical games all of
them ended in a draw but if you remember
last year there was that match that was
organized between Magnus Carlsen and
ding leerin in rapid and blitz time
controls were cousin completely
obliterated ding as you can see
including rapid exhibition games cost
and beating leerin 17 to 2 with 16 draws
so quite a blow but after that treatment
by Carlsen ding immediately went on his
unbeaten streak that has been lasting so
far and it's very interesting to see how
it will end how it will be after this
game also I posted a tweet yesterday
saying that what are your thoughts on
the course and being a leader in an
encounter
80% of you said that Carson will no
longer be rated number one in the world
fifty-one percent thought that the ding
will lose his streak and 31 percent of
you answered that you hope it will be a
draw so a very interesting and as usual
we do have a couple of nice live footage
videos from Nikki Riga so let's enjoy
those as well I did lower the video a
bit more as it seemed a bit too loud yet
again so here we have a nice nice
footage of ding let's just enjoy that
for a moment you can see that he really
came prepared what would some nice shirt
there we have it
ring what's the play there still haven't
figured out why why it's lagging I'm
pretty sure it's due to my terrible PC
configuration and here we have a nice
footage of Magnus Carlsen there we have
it he came prepared were to take that
t-shirt so I do hope you enjoyed this as
well and we do have another one but this
one I'm prepared saving for later so
without further ado Carlson has the
white pieces like we've already
mentioned and he opens with E 4 we have
e5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 Knight the
c3 in the 9th to f6 so here we have the
four Knights game and which d4 we
entered the Scotch variation it captures
on d5 and now Knight captures on d5 I
always enjoy mentioning this in this
position in 1954 at all played Knight to
d5 this is the Belgrade gambit to the
Scotch and with this move he defeated
Yuri overbook and after this game pal
was awarded his Grandmaster title so
even though Yuri Yuri lost some time but
he spent so much time figuring out how
to counter this Belgrade gambit that
Indian it cost him the game but ok knife
captor sandy for Bishop to b4 and the
knight captors in c6 by Carlsen B
captors on c6 and Bishop to d3 as this
is the Scotch it's very thoroughly
analyzed so all of them are swimming in
familiar waters here he captures on d5
we have castles cross and castles and
now C captures on d5 Bishop to g5
pinning the night and now comes c6 we
have Queen to f3 by Carson and all of
the moves so far have been played pretty
much instantly by both players but
should the back to d6 now comes h3 h6
kicking the bishop back Bishop to f4
challenging the bishop on d6 and now
comes rook to b8
attacking the pawn on b2 across and
plays B 3 this is the first mover score
across and barely spent any time I
believe he spent like a minute and half
on this move rook the b4 by doing a very
nice active move by the rook that comes
with a double attack against Constance
Bishop on f4 and here Carson exchanges
bishops Bishop captures Queen captures
in the now comes look F 2 e1
we have a five and here comes rook to d1
and here is the first move we're being
decided what the play that took him some
time for his next move
ding spent some five minutes and he
played the Bishop to d7 and it's very
interesting if you consider blacks
position here you have these pawns here
perhaps submission to rush up to b7 is
also a nice move to consider as you are
planning to push c5 and d4 at some point
seems you want your bishop to be
attacking the King here but it would
actually be a mistake because a3 really
questions the rooks position here you
can go b6 because neither they four will
trap the rook
so after this a3 move you'd have to play
something like a rope to a four but then
comes Queen to e3 and now you have
problems with black the best of being on
B 7 and the not on D 7 does not regard
the D the e8 Square and now you can't
even develop the rook here because of a
nice attack here as the bishop is
covering h7 square and here better up to
h7 wood in the end that wind the piece
for white so uh definitely you know
worth spending five minutes on this
position so Bishop to d7 again nicely
nicely developing the bishop and now the
bishop also covers this square so rook
to e8 will not be a problem in the
future
we have Queen to e3 by crossing and now
comes rub the c8 rook to e8 seems like
like a nice idea the queen is attacked
if the Queen moves okay you exchange a
pair of rooks and then you have another
look that is already active the problem
is this Queen to a7 move that comes with
an attack against the a7 pawn and now
okay you can exchange anyone but what
what we will definitely be better here
so after Queen to b3 we have looked to
see it a move that is ready to meet
Queen to a7 with Queen to c7 I offering
a trade of Queens and also the Queen
from c7 will guard the pawn on e5 and
this is in fact exactly what calls in
place and it is the best idea as the
engine definitely agrees with him and
here for his next move
ding spent some 15 minutes because most
likely he was preparing to meet Queen to
a7 with Queen to c7 and this is
definitely fine but he started exploring
a different idea
and it is this different idea that he in
fact played rockledge for a very nice
idea because his bishop is already
eyeing the age to respond isn't the
knight is ready to jump to g4 and the
Queen is also eyeing the king side so a
lot of attacking potential here one one
such idea would be if Carson actually
captures this pawn then Bishop captures
on h3 will result in a very deadly
attack after G captures rook captures
the threat is Queen coming to h2 so
something like King to f1 and now look
to h1 or King moves and the rook to e8
check King moves now comes Queen to f4
check and here after captures you would
capture here and black will win his
material back he will be up the exchange
and with a much better would would a
winning position
so after this rook to h4 move course and
of course did not capture he played rook
to e3 brought a rope to help out with
the defense of the h3 pawn and here ding
did play Queen to c7 now defending his
8th a five pawn we have Queen captures
on c7 call Sinatra its Queen's rook
captures and now comes Knight to a4 a
very nice move as Carson doesn't want to
put his Knight and c5 this would be
excellent to prevent ding from advancing
his pawns so ding of course prevents
this he pushes c5 himself and here here
is the first critical moment of the game
we can say a very important moment in
the game where Carson can go for night
to b6 or with ideas of capturing this
Bishop also pressuring the d5 pawn and
after Bishop to e6 getting out of the
way
pushing c4 and as the night and Bishop
are safeguarding the c4 pawn all would
be well here in the game continues but
here it seems as if Carlsen saw that
supercomputer line from his game against
Don chenko where he didn't play g4 so in
this game he does play g4 he plays g4
and it seems and it seems that this rook
is somewhat trapped here there's really
no wood Square for it but he misses one
move from dink dink challenges this
position would be for attacking Carlson
look here and this rook has to stay here
it has to keep an eye on the h3 pawn but
now there's a problem
if you play rook to g3 you get rook
captures on h3 rook captures and Bishop
captures on g4 with an attack on this
roof and also Carlson's rook on d1 is
unguarded
so after something like rook captures on
a six you get rook captures on d1 rook
has to go back and now after Bishop to
f3 it will be a very dangerous position
for white as black blacks position is
much more active and also in this whole
process being will have one upon so
after d4 across and played rook to f3
but now Dean has a different idea
you can still play rook captures on h3
here but he plays an even better move
Knight captures on g4 and what's the
idea behind Knight captures on g4 here
cross and spent seven minutes on his
next move because you really have to
calculate a lot of things if you accept
the knight pawn captures here then you
get Bishop to c6 and you are in big
problems your look is under attack here
if you move the rook and there's a
really no good square for you to move it
if you move it here you get checkmated
rope to H 1 will be checkmate
on the other hand if you don't move it
if you play something like Bishop to e2
defending it this is where the magic
happens
after defending it rook to e7 attacking
the undefended de Bishop King to f1
guarding it and now comes h5 a pretty
nice move to find especially when you're
considering all of this because now the
threat is of course H captures on g4
with an attack on the rope you can't
move the rook rook to h1 will still be
checkmate so G captures on h5 but now
comes look to h1 check King to g2 now
comes rook captures on h5 still this
rook is pinned King to f1 and now look
back to h1 check King to g2 and Dena
comes rook captures on d1 Bishop
captures on d1
and now comes Luke to e1 and now the
bishop has nowhere to go you have to
defend it with the knife to be 2 and now
g5 this is amazing what hidden
possibilities there are in this position
and this is pretty much all forced as
now g4 is a threat and your King is
still unable to move as the bishop
captures here is a threat firstly if the
King moves of course route will capture
the defender of the rook and only then
bishop
the rook is an idea so here you have to
figure out what to do if you play
something like King to g3 to meet this
we're moving the rook it doesn't work
because of rogue g1 check King has to
move and now rook captures on d1 Knight
captures and after Bishop captures here
again black will be up upon and with a
much better position and the bishop
against tonight with play on both sides
of the board black will be much better
if not winning here so definitely a lot
of things to consider here and that's
why it took Austin a whole seven minutes
to do it
so cross in place rook to e1 simply gets
the rook out of the this is d1 square of
being undefended and here being simply
moves the knight back so in this whole
process a lot of this madness was
avoided but they managed to snatch a
pawn
it's okay Knights the be 6 by Carlsen
attacking this Bishop we have Bishop to
c6 now attacking crossings rockin f3 and
now rook to g3 and here g5 a very nice
move by by ding as it allows this rook
this maneuvering between h4 and f4 and
the King can come into the game and
there are no in any back back rank
issues in the future so rook to e5 by
Carson attacking the c5 pawn and here we
have knife to h5 attacking Carlson's
rook here and it seems very dangerous
why would cross and allow this his rook
really doesn't have any squares the
bishop is slicing all the way here
there's really no move for Carlsen
structure but this was Carson's idea
Bishop to f5 a very nice move because
now if Knight captures and g3f captors
and g3 now things the rook is indeed
trapped so it's really you know Delta G
for move although it was indeed a
blunder in the end the dings rook is
constantly stuck on h4 and here after
something like f6 attacking the rook
road goes to e1 and the rook has nowhere
to go if you play here then Bishop to g4
will trap the rook and there's really
nothing to do here so as from Bishop to
a5
we have rope to f4 you have to get the
rook out of the h4 Square and here look
the g4 now if you play rook captures
here and then you get H captors on g4
with an attack on
night-night goes back and then you lose
the c5 pawn this was the idea behind
Carlson's rook to e5 move so didn't
immediately place the rook to f3 forces
across and to make an exchange here and
now the rook is also defending the c5
pawn so we have rook captures on f4
Knight captures on f4 and now comes
Knight to d7 we have C 4 as the
deponents if I was under attack and here
comes the Bishop captures on c4 you
don't really have any useful moves here
with something like Knight to f6 simply
King to f8 and now there is no way to
push for anything here or or even force
a perpetual because if anything you will
get your knight trapped here so after
c4b captures on c4 rook captures on c4
and the now cross and really has to
decide what to do here this Bishop and
Knight are very dangerous around Carlsen
skin covering all of very important
squares and the ideas like rook to be 4
to be 1 will definitely be full of mate
threats
so Carlsen calculates precisely he does
have time to grab this a 5 point rook
after Sunday if I was played and now
comes Luke to be four again ding
calculates precisely d3 was also an idea
what if you play this and then of course
you cannot capture with the C pawn
because the rook to see one checked but
if Bishop captures here now the bishop
is no longer guarding the h3 pawn so you
could play Knight captures on h3 but
after came to f1 and rook to be four now
the problem is the bishop from d3 is
also guarding the be 5 square so you
will no longer be able to have any
threats along the B file as now course
and has rook to b5 so after rook
captures on e5
immediately worked to be four by ding
and the knock comes King to h2 i course
and cannot allow work to be one to come
with check and now of course he will he
will be able to escape reacting to g3 if
he played something carelessly like
let's say rook to a6 going for a pawn or
something like that then he is indeed
getting checkmated with this rook to be
one check just so we see what the threat
is and now Knight 3 - this would the
knight and Bishop would create a wall
against the White King and now there is
defense against rook to h1 so Carson has
to make something happen a king to h2
now the King can come to g3 if the Dean
persists and Dean in fact it does
persist we have worked to be one and now
not going for King to g3 immediately but
it could also have been played if King
to g3 attacking the bishop bishop goes
back to c6 attacking the knight now
comes Knight to f6 check King the g7 and
now Bishop to g4 forcing the trade of
bishops here Bishop captures Knight
captures and now after rook to g1 check
King to H 2 root 2 c1 attacking the c2
pawn but now after rook the c5 defending
it it's hard to say because now you can
simply attack dat point and then white
can go back defending it so this would
definitely have been a possibility for
Carlsen if he immediately went the King
to g3 but you know who would do this
instead he goes Knight to e5 and ok we
have worked to h1 check King moves to g3
and now a bishop to d5 you have to get
the bishop out of the way as the bishop
is under attack and now the white king
really doesn't have all that many
squares this Knight is threatening the
drum to eat you would check for example
if Carlsen starts pushing his pawn then
Knight 3 to check will be very dangerous
our King has to move now comes Rob you
want check King has to move and talking
to g7 will create a nice mating net
which ideas of Bishop coming to g4 with
the ideas of Bishop coming to f3 if this
Knight moves and also this night can
come to a4 so something like Knights to
d3 Bishop to f3 check Bishop blocks the
shop captures H captures and now rope to
H 1 will be checkmate this is only one
of the variations that could happen so
after Bishop to d5 f3 you do have to
make the room for the king if 90 to
check then the King can escape vif do we
have rook to e1 attacking Carlsen's
knight on e5 and now comes the Knights
to d3 we have King to rook to g1 check
and here cousin played into f2
also possible was King - H - but no
madman
would you do this here you would have to
allow rook to G to check King to h1 and
Bishop captures on f3 threatening all
sorts of crazy discoveries here and now
you would have to find that Knights the
e1 is is is fine for white after d3
Knight captures on f3 rook to f2 now you
can't save the night and allow this pawn
to be pushed to d2 so you have to react
to this Bishop captures rook captures
here and it seems that although you will
lose the h3 pawn you still have to pass
the pawns on the Queen side and this
will give you in a sufficient counter
play but you know after this check who
what madman would play his King on h2
it's okay we have King - f - this is
move 40 add cross and just made his move
40 and the ding has to make his 40th
move to reach time control here he
played a rook to g2 check and it's very
interesting cross and saw this move
being plated he went away from the board
then across and saw this move and then
he also went away from the board and
there was no one at the board so the the
team captain of alkaloid offered in
clearance team complained to the chief
arbiter about this that there was no one
at the board and that cousin shouldn't
see the move and only then decide to
leave the board so the arbiter had to
look for him in the toilet and we even
have a footage from Nikki riga from this
incident there we have it
this is boarding a rope the g to check
the jump in plate and there is no one
so very very nice so yeah I do hope you
enjoyed that as well
so after they have returned from
wherever after work to G to check King
to e1 Carlson doesn't want to go King to
f1 and allow the spin with Bishop to c4
so instead he goes King to e1 but it
doesn't help him
ding simply plays rook to e2 check
Carson goes back to f1 and only now does
being played Bishop to c4 we have came
to g1 by Carson and now Luke back to G
to check King to h1 and now comes Bishop
captures on d3 it seems that here it was
the pressure of ding in being on his
unbeaten streak and facing the world
champion Magnus Carlsen was too much
pressure for him to to play the the
better move rook captures on c2 it does
put your rook against the mask of this
bishop but after Knight captors and
therefore you do have Dean between roof
to see one check King g2 and now G
captures on f4 and now it's very
dangerous because this past point is is
a really fast pawn so you have to
prevent it with rotate check King g7 and
you have to put this room behind the
passport now not allowing it to be
pushed as both both bishop and rook are
guarding not the d3 square if the pawn
is pushed and also you have to protect
the d4 pawn but perhaps things saw here
that he would have to waste the move or
something and then cousin skin would be
in time but here ding most likely miss
King to f6 a very nice smooth that comes
up with an attack against crossness
Bishop and after he moves it then comes
King e5 and now the King is guarding the
pawn and all this well for black didn't
keeps his extra pawn and he will now be
able to start improving and pushing the
pawn so yeah after King to h1 being
played Bishop captures on b3 now we have
Bishop captures on d3 and the now comes
rook to g3
he wants to grab this point but it's you
can't grab it
since the knight is also guarding the
rope and g1
so you do have to move it did indeed
play rock to g3 also possible was ripped
to d2 simply now threatening to capture
it but also to
capture here twice and now after Bishop
to f5 defending they should report now
rook to f2 attacking this pawn and now
after Bishop guards now you will be able
to capture this pawn but then cross and
can start pushing his a for pawn and
it's a again heart hearts to allow such
counter play to the world champion it's
okay
Bishop captures on d3 as we've said root
2 G 3 now wooden attack against both h3
and f3 pawn but here cousin has
something repaired he plays h4 with
ideas of either ruining black's pawn
structure on the kingside which will
make it not very impressive and then
Bishop 3/4 will guard the f3 pawn and
then cousin can start pushing his own
passport or as it was played in the game
being played rook to h3 check now we
have came to g1 and now comes a rocket
captures on h4 Bishop to F 1 and here it
seems that when Carson played that g4
move it seemed that it was a blunder but
it seems that for this entire game dink
the finding indeed does have a paralyzed
rook on h4
so King to g7 you don't want to get the
knight out of the way to try and get the
rook into the game and Carlsen starts
pushing his passed pawn Knight to g6 we
have looked the c5 now making room to
start pushing his past pawn and now
comes the d3 biding opening up a
discovered attack against this pawn
across and simply place a 5 if you
decide to capture here and allow rook
captures here then without to this
outside passed pawn black is simply up a
pawn and with a much better position
this will be winning 4 black so Crossan
decides to play it precisely we have a 5
and now comes D captures and c2 route
captures on c2 and the now rook to a 4
we have a 6 carlson's Bishop from f1 is
guarding his passport on a6 and here we
have h5 a much better mood would have
been rooked nice to e5 this comes with
an attack against the f3 pawn and now
after Bishop to e2 rook to a3 again with
more attacks against this opponent after
King defends it and only now h5 and now
it's a much more active position where
black would push for the win but still
it's hard to say if it would be enough
after a 6 8
immediately we have worked the c5
attacking the g5 pawn now comes King to
f6 defending and now rub the c6 with
check King to g7 and after rook to c5
came to f6 cross and repeated rook to c6
check King to g7 it was in this move it
was in this position on more 57 that
they agreed to a draw so it seems that
the Twitter poll was not not very
correct see only 18% of you was said
that there's a chance that cross and we
lose this game well it was only Carlsen
for the entire game that was you know
hanging by a thread
it doesn't help ding if instead of going
here he decides to go deeper into the
position because here rook c5 checked
and for example if you want to threaten
here this rook to c4 check will be
deadly because now after captures
captures there's no stopping it call
since a pawn so yeah a lot of a lot of
not a lot of but some missed chances for
ding and if anything didn't really
showed this game that he is a machine
when it comes to calculating and that he
is really forced to be reckoned with and
I think he will be the worst nightmare
of every player in the next candidate
series and if he continues like this
perhaps he will be unbeaten up until the
next candidate series swam I do hope you
enjoy that and all of the footage by
Nick Eureka
here as usual all of the links to her
social media to her Twitter and
Instagram account will be in the
description below also feel free to
follow her as we really are enjoying
some amazing footage ah I would like to
thank Hunter Jones lunar coats peter
Livesay came in darkest and france
hilber for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon hopefully with
some more interesting content thank you
all and see you soon